my name is Antonella Nothe I work for
the European Space Agency because the
Hubble mission is a partnership program
between NASA and easie
I have been fortunate enough to be with
the Hubble project since before launch
so I in a sense I have lived through all
the phases and several years ago I think
probably 10 years ago we were thinking
of doing a survey of young clusters in
the small Magellanic Cloud which was a
relative unchartered territory and we
had selected just on the basis of some
ground-based images a few areas of
interest they look like some little
bubbles with some puffs of gas and dust
maybe some some stars and one of these
was NGC 602 relatively unknown and I
remember when we first saw the image
coming down from the camera we looked at
it and it was just a plain black and
white and polished all reduce image and
me and my team look at each other and we
said this is going to be on the cover of
every single Hubble book and the ten
years later you know we see it on the
cover of every single book because it's
such a beautiful amazing image and the
beauty goes with the scientific
information that that image has given us
because the area our NGC 602 is is an
area which is kind of a desert there is
a match in terms of gas and dust so in
the middle of nowhere seeing this little
cocoon of gas and dust forming stars is
basically you know we've all gone wow
this is phenomenal we were not expecting
this
there are so many another one I will say
is I'm sixteen the pillars of creation
it's hard to describe or quantify some
images just do that today they connect
you with the universe in ways that you
know are totally unexpected